[Musique]
une seule question se pose aujourd'hui
allez-vous en matière de retraite
utiliser le 49-3 oui ou non
depuis maintenant plus de vies jour que
le projet de loi est ici présenté à
l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée nationale a consacré
beaucoup de son temps à la discussion de
l'esprit de la réforme
peut-être mais aussi 9 heures à la
discussion de l'intitulé du titre eu
vingt et un temps considérable à se
poser la question de savoir s'il fallait
remplacer les termes considérant paru
égard annuellement par chaque année où
chaque année par annuellement et que le
temps consacré à ces échanges
parfaitement respectable que je ne
conteste pas le temps passé à ces
échanges ne me paraît pas porté sur le
sens profond d'une réforme ambitieuse
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
si au bout de très nombreuses heures de
débats nous constatons que ça n'est pas
possible alors la constitution alors la
constitution monsieur abad et monsieur
le président vous le savez parfaitement
autorise le cas échéant le premier
ministre a utilisé un article le 49 3
lorsqu'il faut prendre ses
responsabilités je le fais sans hésiter
et j'utilise tout la constitution rien
que la constitution mais bien toute la
constitution
près de 80 mille personnes ont été
contaminées par le grenat virus dans le
monde et en europe nos voisins et amis
italiens sont aujourd'hui les plus
touchés et je veux leur dire notre nom à
tous notre solidarité
il n'est pas nécessaire d'ajouter à la
crise un climat de psychose
c'est pourquoi je vous demande monsieur
premier ministre
de faire toute la transparence sur la
gestion de cette épidémie
c'est la condition pour créer un climat
de confiance climat qui permette la
mobilisation de tous et la
stigmatisation d'aucun les
manifestations d'hostilité envers nos
compatriotes d'origine asiatique sont à
cet égard aussi irrationnel
qu'inadmissibles pour ces raisons je
souhaite que comme pour l'état d'urgence
vous réunissiez les chefs de parti et
président de groupe parlementaire je
suggère également que l'ensemble des
élus notamment nos mères de métropole et
d'outre-mer soit étroitement associée
aux plans qui vont être développées ce
sont eux qui sont d'ores et déjà
interpellé très directement sur le
terrain la priorité unique et absolue du
gouvernement vous en doutez bien c'est
de protéger nos concitoyens contre le
risque et le risque sérieux d'une
épidémie de ce corps d'un virus apparu
en chine et dont tout indique qu'il est
en train de se transmettre un peu
partout dans le monde et que nous nous
trouvons dans une situation qui pourrait
se traduire par une épidémie mondiale ça
n'est pas moi qui le dit monsieur le
député c'est l'eau et baisse nous avons
veillé à ce que le dispositif français
soit prêt
cela passe par la mise en vigilance d'un
certain nombre de centres hospitaliers
d'abord les chu puis 70 centres
supplémentaires ce qui veut dire que
partout en france où il ya un service de
sa bulle nous sommes prêts à accueillir
d'éventuels malade nous constatons qu'il
n'y a aucun malade hospitalisé en france
aujourd'hui atteints par ce virus
aucun je me tient évidemment à la
disposition pour organiser avec
l'ensemble des présidents et des groupes
je pense que monsieur le député vous
l'avez entendu l'ensemble des présidents
de partis politiques et des groupes
parlementaires
une réunion pour dire très exactement où
nous en sommes en ayant conscience que
la situation exigera des mesures au fur
et à mesure que nous en saurons plus
[Musique]